a Manhattan art gallery owner was
apparently beaten for walking down the
streets of New York and a maggot at the
news networks black out the story but
they make sure to spend lots of time
covering the possibility that Trump
supporters at a trump rally might chant
send her back we examine why people hate
the press then the Elijah Cummings has
his house broken into just hours before
Trump tweets about the dangers of living
in Baltimore is Trump summoning some
sort of dark psychic force to predict
the future
no but we'll examine his simple trick
for prediction finally the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
by the way we have breaking news coming
out the American rapper ASAP rocky who
is being held in a Swedish jail has now
been released he's on his way back to
the United States President Trump just
tweeted about it quote ASAP rocky
released from prison and on his way home
to the u.s. from Sweden it was a rocky
week get home ASAP ASAP he tweeted about
this Trump has been central in this
story because when ASAP Rocky was first
held in this jail he had some of his
pals his mutual friends with the
president like Kanye West call up Trump
and say please help get ASAP rocky out
of out of the jail Trump made a big
issue about this behind the scenes to
the Swedish government then he tweeted
about it to the Swedish Prime Minister
then he had a phone call with a Swedish
Prime Minister Swedish Prime Minister
said no Trump didn't take no for an
answer
now ASAP rocky is coming home this is a
great story all around and because I
think I can predict the future or at
least it seems that way it ties in
perfectly with our theme today president
Trump's crystal ball why it seems like
he can just predict the future he says
that Elijah Cummings and Baltimore is a
terrible place he says you know it's
rat-infested it's written with crime and
unbeknownst to anybody just hours
earlier Elijah Cummings house had been
broken into in Baltimore what is that
about it all has to do with ideology
that's what it all boils down to we'll
get to that in a second but first I have
got to thank my friends over at
expressvpn you know me I'm on the
internet all the time I'm not just
browsing I'm literally on the internet
it's practically where I live you are
too that means that our precious data
are just out there for everybody to take
and I know what you're thinking cuz I
used to think this nobody wants my data
Oh what about me nobody's gonna try to
get my data bs everyone is trying to get
your data there's a lot of stuff that
you don't want to get out your financial
information some your personal emails
all those weird websites that you've
been looking at on the incognito browser
tab you know what I'm talking about I'm
talking about Daily wire calm you know
that you've got to protect your data so
expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone
then you just use the Internet like you
normally would you download the app you
click to connect voila you're protected
that's it you don't need to think about
it again expressvpn costs less than
seven bucks a month think about what you
spend seven bucks a month on think about
the frivolous nonsense that you don't
need that you spend seven bucks you
could spend seven bucks on it like one
and a half cups of coffee protect your
privacy your whole life is on the
internet practically these days
expressvpn uses cutting-edge technology
called trusted server to make sure there
are no logs of what you do online
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months free at
expressvpn comm slash michael e XP ress
VPN comm slash michael mi CH AE l for
three months free with a one-year
package expressvpn comm slash michael to
learn more can president trump predict
the future does he have a marianne
williamson esque
crystal ball where he summons the dark
psychic forces and sees into the future
no but it sometimes seems like it is and
there's a very simple reason for this
the reason is ideology that a great
here's a great example of it that
actually doesn't directly involve Trump
the mainstream media so the mainstream
media they're like the counter example
the Trumpkin looks like he can predict
the future the mainstream media can't
see the present they can't even see the
past they distort history they distort
what's going on in the present they're
totally blind to what's going on because
of ideology here's the story a Manhattan
art gallery owner says that he was
beaten by a bunch of thugs in the
streets for wearing a mag aha so he's
got his red hat on make America great
again because I know the mainstream
media will immediately assume it was a
white guy not a white guy I don't know
what his ethnicity is but he certainly
isn't a white guy he's walking around
Chinatown and this guy has a big shiner
on his eye here's his side of the story
chop pad of a bond basically one kid
took
my head am bastard against the
scaffolding pole it all happened within
ten seconds I jumped out across the
street and call the cops okay no reason
not to believe this guy he's got a
pretty brutal gory shiner on his eye and
his cheek his whole whole left side of
his face is swollen up with blood his
eye is basically swollen shut and I'm
not surprised we've seen attacks like
this before
in the u.s. I mean now look even I when
I go out and if I've got my mag a hat on
I look around me because because the
left can be extremely violent I was
assaulted at the University of Missouri
Kansas City and he no actually got
really physically hurt people were
throwing things at him punching him so
this thing does happen we've seen it
happen on camera before it looks like
we're seeing it happen on camera again
to law enforcement sources said that
they're a little skeptical there was a
huge group of people doing it they think
it might have just been a one-on-one
brawl and the guy declined medical
attention on the scene he went later to
get medical attention he was diagnosed
with a bone fracture so the guys kind of
broke his face up a little bit
guess how much coverage this got on the
network news oh zero none none
whatsoever and the reason I keep using
this term allegedly apparently it looks
like is I don't know I guess there's a
small possibility that this was a hoax I
don't know what kind of hoax it would be
where a guy breaks half of his face but
let's say it is compare this to an
actual hoax in the case of Jesse's
Smollett right Jesse's Smollett had
exactly the opposite story that he was
walking down the street and two guys in
maggots came up to him and said hey
Empire because because if someone's
gonna recognize Jesse Smollett on the
street give me a break said hey Empire
this is mega country in south-central
Chicago yeah okay
definitely guys for sure and turns out
the story totally fell apart he paid his
two trainers to come and beat him up
there were two Nigeria and white
supremacists I guess and it was just
total nonsense and he didn't have any
actual injuries the mainstream media the
network news covered that story breath
so the total fake story gets weeks of
coverage the apparently from all we know
for all we can see real story of an
attack from leftists on a Trump
supporter
no network news coverage at all why is
that it's because the fake story fit
their fake ideological narrative and the
real story didn't fit their narrative
and because the real story didn't fit
their narrative they didn't cover it
because of a privilege their ideology
over the reality of what is in front of
them if you went to the mainstream media
and left-wing politicians and you said
hey what are you gonna believe the the
leftist narrative the story that has
been circulating all around the
mainstream press for the last two weeks
or your own lyin eyes what are you gonna
believe what is right in front of you or
the stories that you've all been telling
each other you know that they would pick
the stories they privilege their
ideology over reality nowhere is this
clearer than in the transgender debate I
mean the transgender debate which
affects very few people in a physical
and psychological way has become this a
dominant major political story in a very
prominent TV host might lose his job
because he said that we shouldn't pump
three-year-olds full of hormones and
mutilate their bodies we'll get to that
story but by the end of the show but I
bring it up now to point out between the
ideology of transgenderism and the
physical reality of obviously this man
is a man obviously this woman is a woman
the left is choosing the ideology the
fantasy the delusion the narrative so
instead of covering the actual attack
that happened the networks were covering
the possibility that Trump supporters
might chant send her back at the rally
last night so Trump was holding this
rally last night NBC goes out they asked
the president what will happen if if the
your supporters chant centre-back no
evidence that it's going to happen from
disavowed it after the last time the
first time that it happened there's no
evidence of that but
that's the story they're covering here's
NBC here's Trump's response stop if they
begin chanting something problematic I
don't know what's going to happen I can
tell you this I'm going to Cincinnati
the arena is a very large one and we've
sold it out we could sell it out
probably ten times from what I hear the
the applications for seats as you know
never had an empty seat the applications
are very big I have no idea we have a
great group of people they love our
country they love the job we're doing
there it is right it's all it's all
hypothetical will this happen tonight
what will you do if this does happen
what would it be like if this were to
happen they're not covering a real story
they covered the real story last time
bad that one rally where some people
briefly chanted send her back send her
back they covered it the next day Trump
said I didn't like it I wish they didn't
do it I don't think it's a good thing I
hope they don't do it again so perfectly
legitimate for them to cover it then
great response from Trump that's it now
they're covering a hypothetical story to
President Trump and they keep hammering
it they keep asking well do you have a
message what are you going to say to
them what do you think and Trump has an
excellent answer here
[Music]
I do have a message my message is for
the people I'm going to so we had over a
hundred thousand applications for
whatever the size of the year I think
it's a fourteen thousand seat arena but
we're way over a hundred and I think a
hundred and twenty-two thousand
applications for those seats you know
what my message is I love them and I
think they love me I actually think they
love me
nailed it totally nailed that that's the
answer I love that's my message for them
I love them this is the difference in
the campaign this is actually the
Marianne Williamson principle Marianne
talking about love and the battlefield
of love she actually gets this love is
an important part of politics love
really is the basis of politics love of
country love of your community love of
your family love of your extended
national family that's the basis of
politics love of your ancestors love of
your children that love of your
traditions love of what's going to come
in a few generations this sums up
different approaches of the left and the
right to politics you know the left
leaps to condemn the left would always
just can I condemn this I disavow this I
hate this I hate the past I hate the
future I hate the present I hate George
Washington I hate America I hate all of
it I condemn everything want to tear
down statues the right doesn't leap to
condemn the right wants to improve we
all want to improve obviously there are
plenty of imperfect things this is an
imperfect world you want to improve but
you want to start it from a place of
love you can see this in the Academy in
the Universities the universities are a
crystal ball they're the future of the
country you look at the university 20
years from now that's what you're going
to get is your country and the
universities did this in the 1970s it's
really coming to fruition now they began
indoctrinating students in curricula of
critical theory is what it's called what
Harold Bloom the literary critic called
it is the school of resentment so the
prior approach to reading a piece of
literature or looking at some text is
you come from it loving it you you
enjoy it you want to learn from it you
want to gain wisdom from it you want it
to and maybe entertain you maybe edify
you maybe enlighten you but that's the
act of reading is comes from that place
of love it's an enjoyment it's a
pleasure what the school of resentment
does is you you totally flip that on its
head so instead of opening up I don't
know I'll use an example actually from
that literary critic Harold Bloom
instead of opening up Walt Whitman great
American poet kind of the American poet
one of them you open up leaves of grass
and you say what can I learn from Walt
Whitman what does this poem tell me
about America instead you open it up and
you say how is this guy a racist how is
this guy a sexist how much better am I
than this guy I hate this guy how wrong
was he that's the school of resentment
Harold Bloom actually one time in an
interview I believe what the Paris
Review said that a graduate student came
into his class and said we just had an
American Studies lecture for two hours
about how Walt Whitman is a racist that
that is the different approach you can
approach it from from love or you can
approach it from resentment but the Left
approaches from resentment and I think
that's fueling a lot of the backlash
against elites in the media and elites
in politics and what it's really fueling
is president Trump's crystal ball what
it's really fueling is president Trump's
uncanny ability to predict predict
things he's not predicting anything it's
just that the resentful left is getting
it all wrong the ideological left is
getting it all wrong we'll see how that
plays out we'll see what that means by
the way for international politics first
I've got to thank our friends over at
Quicken Loans support for the Michael
Nolt show comes from our friends at
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans finding
the right house is not easy I live in
Los Angeles it's impossible to find the
right house here because the minute you
do you realize it cost seven trillion
dollars and they're gonna add a heap of
property tags it's just it's just awful
here the good thing is though once I do
find that home of my dreams I know that
the mortgage process is going to be made
very easy because we've got the team of
mortgage experts at Quicken Loans they
are obsessed with finding a better way
they have industry leaning
online lending technology developed in
the heart of Detroit rocket mortgage is
changing the game they make the prom
buying process work for you it's there
with award-winning client service and
support every step of the way this is
why Quicken Loans has ranked highest in
customer satisfaction for primary
mortgage origination nine years in a row
and highest in mortgage servicing five
years in a row
look I it's a very awful complicated
process in general to buy a house
Quicken Loans is the best they're gonna
make it easy for you this is one of the
most important decisions you're ever
going to make use the best to get it
done get started online at rocket
mortgage comm slash Knowles Kay no wles
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states
n MLS consumer access Dorgan number 30
30 rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage this is what is
fueling a lot of the resentment against
the elites of both parties and the media
etc it's it's this feeling that they
hate the American people you know my
friend Elena plot over at the Atlantic
just has a piece ad today and she was
covering the strum pralli and she said
the big takeaway is these Americans
don't want to be called racist all the
time they don't want to be called
deplorable they don't want to be called
irredeemable they're not racist
you know she interviews one grandmother
who said she goes look I have 10
grandkids two of them are black one of
them's biracial ruins this one's that
you know I don't I'm not a racist I just
like my country I love my country and I
don't I don't want to be smeared all the
time by people in office and and people
who are in the media perfectly fair
point but the the because the left
because the media really are filled with
this resentment at the people of this
country at the country itself at the
history of this country at the
institutions in this country they have
to cover the hypothetical mean chant
over the actual attack on a trump
supporter they have to cover they they
they would much rather cover that
because that confirms their narrative
that America's really xenophobic
nativist bigoted awful terrible place
they would much rather cover that than
an attack on a
Trump supporter what is that what is the
story of the attack on the Trump
supporter show now maybe the
Conservatives aren't fascists maybe the
Conservatives aren't hopelessly racist
maybe actually they've been
misrepresented by the media maybe they
just want to as the Hat says make
America great again maybe there's a
little violence from the left maybe the
left is fueled by violence maybe some
Trump supporters are being attacked
maybe everybody needs to calm down a
little bit maybe people need to stop
portraying Trump as Hitler that can't be
the case because they have their
narrative in their head so instead it's
all the hypothetical hypothetical Trump
is the force of darkness is evil is
wicked and the leftists are going to
bring us out of that awful awful America
that we all know into that new utopia
they're going to as President Obama used
to say fundamentally transform America
why do they have to fundamentally
transform it because America is rotten
to the core and so you've got a
fundamentally transforming if you want
to have a good country look politics is
a contact sport okay and conservatives
were very hard on Obama I'm not saying
they were were not hard on Obama but
there is something different in the
quality of the left's attacks on Trump
and Trump supporters than there was in
the attacks unconservative from
conservatives toward Obama listen to how
Morning Joe describes President Trump at
his rally he actually reminded you know
yeah you see the Austin Powers movies oh
yeah did you see the awesome power yeah
yeah he sort of reminded me at times
like a fat bastard at times he was like
looking at the audience ooh Mary
character it's a character yeah it's a
character in Austin Powers and he's
sniffing and he's looking order thank
you think I thought he was gonna say
goods into my stomach
at one point um this is a guy he is as
David Brooks said this morning in the
New York Times this is a guy is a force
and the only way the Democrats are going
to beat him is with an equal force the
thing that the last night's rally showed
and it was a great I think I think it
was a great comparison with what the
Democrats were doing it showed that here
was a guy that strutted across
stage he was at being he was being a
demagogue I would say Mussolini like
just just picking at racial resentments
constantly he's a fat bastard racist
fascist Mussolini that's what he is
according to the very serious very
reasonable and very civil voices who
wear suits and ties over at MSNBC that's
what he is he's a fat bastard right
imagine imagine if a conservative on
television on Fox News had made fun of
Barack Obama's appearance I don't know
if Obama wasn't fat but I don't know
made fun of his appearance in some way
could you imagine the outcry first of
all they'd be fired immediately
whichever commentator said that imagine
look there was one time at a at a rodeo
in 2013 when a rodeo clown wore a mask
of Obama and kind of danced around out
there in the rodeo he was instantly
fired why I still couldn't tell you I
don't know you just weren't really
allowed to make fun of Obama because
anytime you said anything about Obama
you were called a racist and a bigot
even though it didn't have any basis in
reality this we've talked in the last
week and a half or two weeks we've
talked a lot about fantasy versus
reality okay and this is where this is
where you see in the media's awful
behavior in the left's awful behavior
you see why it appears that Donald Trump
can predict the future because the
fantasy is the fantasy is that America
is a terrible place populated by bigots
and fascists that has only ever wrought
evil in the world
in reality the opposite is true America
is the most tolerant the most equitable
the most just the most prosperous the
most free country in history that's not
sentiment that's not just my preference
and love of America speaking it's just a
fact a multi-ethnic multi-religious all
sorts of B multi-religious altogether
we've become the biggest economy in the
world the only superpower left on earth
we've more or less still got
self-government
more or less
still a republic more or less still
encourage freedom personal freedom
freedom of property freedom of movement
the reality is that America like all
countries is imperfect but it's a great
place and Americans are great people and
that's something to feel good about so
that's something to love about it and
that is why Trump keeps getting stuff
right because he's not blinded by this
ridiculous ideology of the left that
tells them to believe their own
narrative over their lyin eyes frankly
he's not even blinded by the various
ideologies that have cropped up on the
right I mean this was the big argument
against him in 2016 is that he's not
ideologically conservative it'd be I
don't know that he's philosophically
conservative I doubt that he's ever read
Edmund Burke or Michael Oakshott or
Russell Kirk he hasn't been steeped in
the conservative movement he didn't
spend all of the 90s and 2000's going to
lunches at the various think tanks in
Washington DC he just sees what's in
front of him he can just see it and
that's why he tends to get things right
it's not that complicated it's not
25-degree chess he just has his eyes
open and he's looking in front of him
and all of these other fools some to the
right of him most of them to the left
are just totally blinded they've got the
blinders of their ideology and the
blinders of their narrative on and so
they can't see what's right in front of
them so some people think he's
Nostradamus he's not he just isn't
blinding himself and this cuts two ways
by the way there's a there's a mostly
good side to this there is some downside
there is some unpleasantness that comes
from his lack of sort of philosophical
or ideological formation so the good
side is it looks like he can predict the
future
you saw this in Baltimore right he
points out how awful Baltimore E is not
does it not that it's intrinsically
awful but it's been just destroyed by
political corruption Democrat led
corruption in that city it's it's been
neglected it's they've gone through what
three mayors in two years or something
and so Trump makes these comments and
then a few days later it comes out that
congressman Elijah Elijah Cummings who
was the object of
Trump's ire there is the Baltimore
congressman had his house broken into
and his s wasn't broken into because
Trump talked about him his house had
been broken in two hours before Trump
talked about him the Baltimore PD came
out and said this burglary took place at
3:40 a.m. on Saturday just hours later
Trump tweets about it is it because
Trump is Nostradamus no it's because
everyone knows how rundown Baltimore is
and they're all just now pretending it
isn't because Trump it Trump talked
about how it is rundown Elijah Cummings
himself used the same language to talk
about Baltimore 20 years ago in 1999
here is I left my community of Baltimore
a drug-infested area where a lot of the
drugs that we're talking about today
have already taken the lives of so many
children the same children that I
watched 14 or 15 years ago as they grew
up now walking around like zombies this
is only 40 miles away from here
so Sanders Bernie Sanders used the same
language about Baltimore mayor of
Baltimore Catherine Pugh use the same
language congressman from Baltimore
Elijah Cummings used the same language
now President Trump uses the same
language and so the left has to oppose
him but Trump got it right because guess
what they were all right about Baltimore
if you predict that somebody is gonna
get their house broken into in Baltimore
you're probably gonna be right right
this is not it's it's a crime-ridden
City so yeah obviously you're going to
be right so and this is the this is the
politically beneficial side for Trump
not really having much ideology I mean
the others a SAP rocky is another
example the more ideological or
philosophically formed presidents might
say well we need to let the justice
system play out there in Sweden we can't
use the bully pulpit of the United
States to pressure a prime minister in
Sweden to release a Shiprock and Trump
just says yeah okay forget about all
that
hey Sweden let my guy go let him go
right now or there's going to be hell to
pay
guess what happens within a week or two
they let the guy go that's the plus side
of not having that philosophical
foundation there is an ugly side to it
there is genuinely an ugly side we'll
get to that in a second first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube then we'll get to the mailbag
too by the way so go over to daily
wire.com ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
intro Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh row
you get guy should get so much you get
another Kingdom you test questions in
the mailbag you get backstage you get
the leftist ears tumblr this is mmm this
is really good this is this is a nice
accompaniment to Trump's crystal ball
because when you have those leftist ears
you just you can predict how things are
going to go it just it opens your mind
man it's like some Marianne Williamson
secret potion I mean it really opens
your mind to the field of love make sure
you go over there get those leftist ears
we'll be right back with a lot more
here's the ugly side to not having that
philosophical and or even perhaps
ideological formation here's the the the
ugly side to just kind of seeing what's
in front of you
president Trump just tweeted out not an
hour ago quote Kim jong-un and North
Korea tested three short-range missiles
over the last number of days these
missile tests are not a violation of our
signed Singapore agreement nor was there
discussion of short-range missiles when
we shook hands there may be a UN
violation but chairman Kim does not want
to disappoint me with a violation of
trust there is far too much for North
Korea to gain the potential as a country
under Kim jong-un's leadership is
unlimited also there is far too much to
lose I may be wrong but I believe the
Chairman Kim has a great and beautiful
vision for his country and only the
United States with me as president can
make that vision come true he will do
the right thing because he is far too
smart not to and he does not want to
disappoint his friend president Trump
where do I begin
obviously most of this tweet objectively
speaking is not true I don't think Kim
jong-un has a beautiful vision for his
country I don't he actually is probably
pretty smart he's been able to hold
power in that country pretty well even
though he got power very young so I
guess he is pretty smart I don't think
he cares really about the friendship
with Donald Trump he may not want to
disappoint Trump because he fears
nuclear missiles landing in in North
Korea but what is this about what is
it's about it's actually about the exact
same thing it's about seeing what's in
front of you President Trump is looking
in front of him and he's seeing a
current ongoing negotiation with North
Korea to get them to denuclearize and
he's saying okay what can I do today
that will make it more likely for Kim to
denuclearize Kim shot off a few short
range missiles what can I do can I
scream and yell about it is that going
to help the negotiation can I not say
anything about it is that gonna help me
negotiation or can I try to flatter Kim
flatter and kind of threaten Kim is that
going to
help the negotiation that's what this is
about
Trump concluded rightly or wrongly that
it was the latter course that by
flattering by reminding Kim that they've
got a good thing going on and that Trump
is the only one who's given Kim an
opening that that is going to help the
negotiation he has one good point here
the one good point is what CS Lewis
writes about in Screwtape Letters which
is that you can only act in the present
in the Screwtape Letters which is this
book you know it's a series of letters
written from one demon to his nephew
about destroying a human soul and the
advice that the demon gives to his his
nephew is always get people thinking
about the future
and always get people thinking about the
past don't let them think about the
present because the present is the only
place where you can actually act it's
the only place where you can make moral
decisions and it's a really good insight
people they harp so much on the future
we're not the future the future is not
the future that we envision almost
certainly will not be what the future
really looks like and we can't change
the past and people are mired and regret
or they're mired in optimism for the
future or dream day dreaming about the
future or preparing to be disappointed
about the future only in the present can
you act which is true that's an
important aspect so President Trump is
saying we're in the present I don't care
what this is going to look like in
history I don't care what this means for
the future I'm just trying to move the
ball down the field
however this tactic strikes our ears is
absolutely egregious because it's untrue
I mean so that you know Kim jong-un is
like one of the worst people on the face
of the earth maybe one of the worst
people in history so ideally what we
would like is for you to be able to act
in the present without this kind of
flattery without this kind of dishonesty
and without this kind of wishful
thinking about Kim this is the first
time since Reagan that we've seen
anything resembling this sort of
behavior and as always Trump turns it up
to 11
so with Reagan you some major overtures
to the dictator of the Soviet Union
Gorbachev who himself positioned himself
as a reformer and they'd go over there I
mean at the Reykjavik
Reagan and Gorbachev we're talking about
abolishing all nuclear weapons meanwhile
Reagan's advisers are saying what are
you doing stuff don't don't talk about
that but you saw a similar kind of
impulse from Reagan Reagan was working
in the present he went when that summit
broke down according to sources in the
room Reagan said to Gorbachev how could
you do this to me very personal you know
this is a personal relationship here
Trump is trying to establish that
personal relationship it's ugly to us we
don't want our president to have a
personal relationship with Kim jong-un
because Kim jong-un is one of the worst
people on earth will this pay off I
don't know it's I don't think it's high
risk for the reputation of the United
States I think whoever the next
president is can do whatever he wants
and change that relationship it's very
high risk for Trump I mean it's he'll
look like a real schmuck if nothing
happens on this Korea thing it's high
risk to his reputation but he's willing
to do it because he lives in the present
that is the advantage of his not being
very ideological and that is the
sometimes ugly and unpleasant
disadvantage of his not being
ideological but that's what it is and
that's why it looks like he can read
into the future I really wanted to get
to this Mario Lopez story this Mario
Lopez story the guy from extra and
Access Hollywood he came out and said
that we shouldn't well we'll just get to
it will narrow the mailbag down I can't
let this go this story is so important
here's Mario Lopez on the Candice Owens
show talking about transgender children
so transgender three-year-olds I'm never
one to tell anyone how to parent their
kids obviously and I could give you
company because you're doing something
right thanks you know and I always say
if you come from a place of love you
know you really can't go wrong but at
the same time my god if you're three
years old and you're saying you're
feeling a certain way or you're you're
you think you're a boy or girl whatever
the case may be I just think it's
dangerous as a parent to make that
determination then okay well then you're
gonna be a boy or girl whatever the case
may be and it's it's sort of alarming
and oh my gosh I just think about the
repercussions later on you don't know
anything about sexuality yet you're just
a kid right that is the most obvious and
simple and restrained and in moderate
statement that you could possibly make
on the subject this is well I just think
it's sort of like a little dangerous you
know to to mutilate your three-year-old
child's genitals and put them on puberty
blocking hormones and shoot them full of
chemicals that will fundamentally change
their biochemistry I just think maybe
it's not a great idea I just think maybe
three-year-olds don't fully understand
their sexuality three-year-olds you sick
perverts three-year-olds they're doing
this and Mario Lopez says you know hey
maybe we shouldn't we shouldn't
sexualize three-year-olds most moderate
statement in the world guess what
they're trying to fire him now
it's a big meeting this at NBC I guess
it is to to try to get him to lose his
show he had he issued an apology it's
really pathetic
but I guess look he's got a got a lot of
kids got a raise his family don't want
to lose all his money here's what Mario
Lopez then said later quote the comments
I made were ignorant and insensitive and
now I have a deeper understanding of how
hurtful they were I have been and always
will be an ardent supporter of the LGBT
to convey LGBTQ community I'm going to
use this opportunity to better educate
myself moving forward I will be more
informed and more thoughtful oh my gosh
this guy this guy look he had to do it
I'm sure he didn't write a word of that
I assume his agents at CAA or WME or
wherever he's represented all his
lawyers probably wrote that up
well what trash I mean what a trash
statement and what a trash culture that
would pillory him for this and they're
still probably gonna make him lose his
show because the left is vindictive they
don't forgive he shouldn't have backed
down from this it from a moral
standpoint he shouldn't have back down
but just from a practical standpoint
it's never enough appeasement doesn't
work with these sick leftists these sick
perverts are abusing children and are
shooting them full of chemicals at age
three and sexualizing them and changing
their body chemistry and mutilating
their bodies they're sick perverts who
should be locked up for life at least
and that's how we should talk about it
there's no end to this this is gender
ideology
and we conservatives want to talk about
this for the actual small very small
number of people who suffer from a
psychological condition where they're
confused about their biological sex and
we just want to be really nice and
compassionate some people even want to
indulge that delusion because it's sort
of easier and seems polite it's not
about them it actually isn't the left
isn't making this an issue because of
them the left is making this an issue
because it is a radical power grab it is
not just a grab for political control or
economic control or even cultural
control it is a power grab for
ontological control to control the power
to redefine reality itself and these
guys are vicious and vindictive it's
coming to a big tech platform near you
they are going to try to pass policies
whereby if you call a man a man and that
man thinks he's a woman you will you
will be kicked off you will be censured
if you say that a parent shouldn't pump
their poor little kid full of hormones
and mutilate their body that you are
some sort of bigot it is it is so
perverse it is so sick and disgusting
and there's no middle ground there's no
moderate I know conservatives want to be
conciliatory I know
Mario Lopez wants to keep his job
sometimes that rubber meets the road
guys you know sometimes there's just a
bridge too far
and this attempt it's not about some
sexual confusion in a small number of
people this is about a full-on onslaught
attempt to redefine reality if
conservatives don't stand for this we
don't stand for anything let's get to
the mailbag in our remaining five or six
minutes from Eli hey Michael I love your
show thank you do you think it's
possible to be a conservative and an
atheist yes I do think it's possible I
was a conservative and an atheist for
about ten years
varying degrees of conservative
libertarian or this or that I just don't
think it's possible to be really
coherently conservative and an atheist
because politics is downstream of
culture and culture is downstream of
religion and that which we are
conserving as Christian civilization so
I don't think it that makes a whole lot
of sense
the one just as a practical matter I
think the way it breaks down is I think
if you are a hardcore evangelical
atheist I think if you're the sort of
atheist who probably has a neck beard
and like thinks that Richard Dawkins is
a really smart philosopher and
theologian and you know you read a
couple Christopher Hitchens columns once
and you think you know anything and
you're if you're the sort of person who
refers to the Bible as a series of fairy
tales if you I don't think then really
you can be a conservative because
conservatives need to have a respect and
a reverence for our tradition
conservatives need to have a sense of
the sacred you know even look our
national monuments in the United States
and Washington DC I was just there last
week
they're not just statues in Washington
they're not just a statue of Lincoln
they are full-on religious temples the
Washington Monument is an Egyptian
religious obelisk the the Lincoln
Memorial is a greco-roman temple right
with it with Lincoln there as Zeus
sitting in a chair that is the reason
that we do that is because nations need
to have a sense of the sacred if you
want to conserve something you need to
have a sense of the sacred so if you are
a sort of amiable atheist if you're the
kind of guy who has a respect for
religious traditions but you just can't
bring yourself to believe which by the
way I think is like most of the culture
right now I think of course you can be a
conservative and I think you're gonna be
on your way to maybe not being an
atheist anymore but if you're that kind
of hardcore it's just it's all
completely wrong and bogus and everyone
who ever lived before me is an idiot and
I'm much smarter than Thomas Aquinas or
Aristotle or somebody if you believe
that I just I don't think you could ever
have the humility or or at the present
you couldn't have the humility to to be
a conservative because the left is
defined by pride and conservative
thought is defined by humility from
Blake can you name all the Democrat
candidates without linking there is a
dopey and sleepy and Dericks wall well
and Donner and cupid and Blitzen I don't
write I don't think I could I I don't
think the other candidates could as well
during the
debate there was a guy named Steve
Bullock from Montana guess that guy's
running for president there's another
guy John Delaney I guess he's running
for prick what I'm doing my favorite of
the three edible candidates his name is
Tim Ryan and he's just like just the
most pitiable okay he's just obviously
not going anywhere
I'm referring to all the candidates that
I've never heard of as Tim Ryan and it
just really limits the field down so you
only need to remember about seven names
and just call everyone else Tim Ryan
that's that's what I would recommend for
for you going forward because it's not
worth memorizing all of those names when
most of them are gonna be gone by the
next debate from Texas fan why isn't
anyone talking about how Marianne
Williamson has led many people astray
with her promotion of the heretical
Course in Miracles
funny you should ask Texas fan I did
that just yesterday I think these
mailbag questions came in yesterday
so check out my episode yesterday on
dark psychic Democrats to get a better
take on that from Mandy
hey Michael as a woman of faith who has
spent her entire marriage trying to
start a family there is something I have
really been struggling to understand why
do you think God allows so many women to
conceive children who were just going to
abort them and I suspect the other side
of that is why why are so many women not
able to conceive or not able to conceive
at the time that they want to conceive
what you're really asking is a very
basic problem which is why does God
permit evil to exist and the answer is
because of the fall of man because God
gave man free will and man chose to
disobey God's will and to to follow his
own will in contravention of God's
desires and therefore sin pervaded the
world and death pervaded the world and
evil has a foothold in this world and
the devil is the Prince of this world
and so the question you asked over why
all these women can conceive just to
abort the kids and why women who don't
want to abort the kids can't conceive
and I mean it's the same question as
wide as a three-year-old to get leukemia
it's the same question is why why do bad
things happen to good people why do bad
things happen at all
obviously we don't have time to go into
the full topic of theodicy or the
problem of evil good book on it is CS
lewis the problem of pain or Lewis again
a grief observed and those are just
really good kind of lay books that you
can introduce you to the question and
there are more advanced books on it but
the the simple answer the Christian
answer is is what we say at Easter which
is if this is the greatest possible
world which I suspect it is then what it
means is that a world in which there is
no free will is not as good as a world
in which there is free will and
incarnation and atonement and the
resurrection so it seems to me if we
didn't have free will if we didn't
genuinely have the ability to deny God
and therefore allow sin and death to
pervade the world then we what world
would it be but you wouldn't even be
conscious I mean it would just be a
robot world it would be like a computer
simulation or something but you do have
free will freedom is a wonderful thing
and what you say on Easter is you you
celebrate the fall of man in a way you
say oh great
oh happy fault that gave to us that one
for us so great and glorious a redeemer
oh happy fault oh FedEx culpa we fell we
disobeyed God that's awful but it won
for us so great and glorious our
Redeemer
in the resurrection that is the way to
think of it it doesn't deny the reality
of suffering it's but it is a comfort
comfort meaning it gives you strength
and allows you to see the glory up ahead
last question from gr V M what is the
origin of ben shapiro of constantly
ripping on you that's a great question
and you'll have to tune in to this
week's sunday special gonna be the
greatest sunday special in the history
of the ben shapiro show sunday special
because it's gonna feature little ol me
so tune in then and i think we'll get
the story of it there all right that's
our show in the meantime I'm Michael
nose this is the Michael Noel's show see
you on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and
makeup by Jesuit Elvira production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey guys over
on the Matt Walsh show today we're gonna
hit on some of the stories we missed
this past week starting with Mario Lopez
he said as you may have heard that
three-year-olds can't choose their own
gender and but he sense almost
immediately cowardly apologize for that
so we'll discuss the need in our culture
for not just sanity but also courage
which is which is so sorely lacking also
is it racist for robots to be white
CNN has posed that very important
question and finally scientists are
trying to create human monkey hybrids
we'll talk about the many moral problems
with something like that today over on
the Matt Walsh show